it's weird to say I'm head of household
because in this household we split
everything 50 50. Gabrielle Union's
comment about her finances with hubby
Dwyane Wade getting mixed reactions on
social media I work my butt off but he
you know every day he gets up and
delivers again and again and again the
actress makes the confession on idea
generation with Noah Callahan bever at
what point
did you develop that first sense of
security and that the work is coming and
there isn't this sort of sense of the
rug is going could could still be pulled
out I struggle with that still just
because I
I think I just have more
responsibilities you know for my money
so
I get nervous like
oh God that that movie didn't open you
know well what does that mean do I am I
do I do am I going to have enough to to
hold everybody up and that's when
Gabrielle explains why bills are split
evenly in their home say I'm head of
household because in this household we
split everything 50 50. but in the other
households that each of us have to
support
it puts this there's always this like
gorilla on your back that it is like you
better work you better work you know
you're gonna sleep in
you know somebody might not eat yeah and
the internet has some thoughts on
Twitter user writes oh how cute they
split their bills 50 50 like regular
folks I'm sure that really helps ease
the anxiety of being a multi-millionaire
workaholic in other tweets this is so
unnecessary as an independent career
woman I don't have a problem with any
woman who wants to support herself and
contribute to paying bills however stop
this portrayal as if you're living
paycheck to paycheck it's not a good
look when hubby's got Mega Bank well
Gabrielle's seemingly responding to the
backlash with this video I am on to see
my husband I'm happy
to see my husband writing in the caption
I love when he matches my energy 50 50
over here he motivates me he he has like
every day I feel like I wake up and he's
got a new deal on that so it makes me go
okay let's keep working let's keep
striving the two have each found
multi-millionaire success on their own
Dwayne who retired from the NBA in 2019
earned close to 200 million dollars over
his career meanwhile Gabrielle's been
acting since 1993 starring in big films
over the years I got the job another
soft Chris
really yeah I mean that's cool and on
top of that she's a businesswoman real
estate investor and author it's all
about perseverance and putting your
family first and loving every member of
your family equally and out loud and
their families why the couple strive for
the best when it comes to their work and
businesses we have opportunities in life
and you try to pick the ones that's best
for you and you know hopefully for your
family as we try to grow this thing
called generational wealth right and so
uh you know I'm just trying to do my
part in doing that and uh this one right
here does her part and there we go
[Music]
good